[Musique]
le
lieu
[Musique]
au risque au risque d'insister
partout
[Musique]
je suis
sur place les investigations débutent
elle débute dans le cas d'une procédure
pénale qui est ouverte sous des chefs de
qualifications suivantes blessure
involontaire accompagnée de la
circonstance aggravante de mise en
danger des libérés de la vie d'autrui
c'est une qualification j'insiste qui a
été choisie parce qu'elle nous a paru la
plus pertinente en raison des éléments
dont nous disposons à l'heure où je vous
parle rien n'exclut que cette
qualification évolue même si nous avons
de premiers éléments qui nous conduisent
à confirmer que cette explosion est
partie de l'immeuble nous avons je crois
un certain nombre d'idées sur les
victimes qui ont pu être transportés à
l'hôpital vous en avez le nombre
certaines sont en urgence absolue
d'autres en urgence relative nous
comptons évidemment sur les victimes en
urgence relative pour nous donner de
premiers éléments d'investigation et de
compréhension de ce qui a pu se passer
mais vu qu'on prendrait quand l'État le
judiciaire nous est apparue s'imposer au
regard du nombre des victimes c'est
c'est à mon avis quelque chose qu'il
faut évidemment comprendre mais que
évidemment toutes les investigations
seront accomplies les investigations
techniques les auditions les
exploitations de caméras de surveillance
autant que de besoin mais en l'état où
je vous parle la priorité a été donnée
évidemment aux soins des victimes et à
la sécurisation des lieux donc c'est un
premier point sur lequel je voulais vous
informer et bien sûr
au fil des heures nous adapterons la
communication judiciaire au gré de
l'évolution des éléments d'enquête de
nous disposerons je ne vous ai peut-être
pas indiqué le service saisie le service
saisie et la direction régionale de
police judiciaire de la préfecture de
police de Paris
cette qualification elle veut dire
simplement que nous allons nous
interroger sur le point de savoir s'il y
a une un non respect d'une
réglementation
ou une imprudence individuelle qui
aurait conduit à cette explosion qui
elle-même aurait conduit à ses blessures
les investigations ça veut dire la mise
en danger des libérée ça veut dire que
là on est plus dans un aspect
réglementaire qui conduirait une option
individuelle à avoir dit je sais je
connais cette cette réglementation mais
je passe outre et je fais telle ou tel
acte qui conduirait à conclure à une
mise en danger délibérée c'est une
qualification
complexe au niveau des éléments de
preuve mais il nous est apparu que nous
devions prendre en l'état de nos
informations le chant d'investigation le
plus large possible pour permettre toute
expertise utile et toute audition utile
je vous remercie et nous poursuivons
donc les
investigations et les recherches et je
vous prie d'excuser mon départ mais il
semble que ce soit attendu
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais ça va
quelque chose sorti
moi ce que je vous propose
il était bien tout à l'heure
c'est
après si je vais sur le côté
[Musique]
vous allez reculer
vous allez tous dans la rue là-bas merci
on va jouer
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
on va passer
devant parce que
là bas
le problème si tu veux c'est que si je
me déplace moi je perds ma place et
parce que il y a beaucoup de caméra
la barrière
[Musique]
avec le Théo
que ça se passe
on va travailler
[Musique]
vous voulez la mettre sur
arrive super large pour payer par un
mais il y a pas de
[Musique]
je raccroche alors
en fait
avoir un peu avant les choses
à dire et à l'heure
la petite ambiance
[Musique]
tu peux demander si
je suis toujours que
je peux avoir
quelques minutes qui nous étions à une
cinquantaine de mètres
de la rue Saint-Joseph de la
viande cutanée
dans le bas que vous
avez passé et pouvoir il y a une
du
monde qui ont besoin de ça
ou bien
ce que je voyage
tout à fait inspirant
à laquelle nous découv
rent des exposés et on va arriver sur ce
chemin il y a des habitants que nous
avons choisi nous voyons
[Musique]
ça peut encore essayer de sortir
du micro
c'est du coup vous
avez en revanche parce que je
jusqu'à tout à l'heure il n'arrive pas à
vous de voir une
bonjour à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur le figarologue nous sommes
en direct du cinquième arrondissement de
Paris c'est ici qu'une détonation s'est
fait entendre il y a maintenant presque
trois heures vous le voyez derrière moi
sur ces images de Julien Leclerc cela
c'est passé à proximité du Val de Grâce
et du Panthéon et donc voilà vous le
voyez c'est ces images assez noire deux
choses très saisissantes très
saisissante pardon ici c'est d'abord ces
sirènes et ses gyrophares que nous
voyons que nous apercevons au loin parce
que évidemment les secours sont à tapis
d'oeuvre pour et bien d'abord et tenter
de circonscrire l'incendie et puis
évidemment de porter secours aux
personnes disparues et puis également
une autre une autre chose ici c'est vous
l'imaginez cette forte odeur cette forte
odeur de fumée cette forte odeur de
cramer que nous ressentons ici à aller
500 600 mètres des lieux de l'explosion
vous le voyez ici un barrage de
policiers de camions que vous apercevez
ici ce sont les camions des CRS qui sont
ici évidemment pour et bien bloquer le
périmètre certains habitants ici que
vous que vous voyez tente et bien de
rejoindre le boulevard du Port Royal le
boulevard du Port-Royal c'est cette
grande rue que vous voyez peut-être
entre le lieu où je me trouve
actuellement et le lieu de l'explosion
et bien il y a ici un boulevard avec un
certain nombre évidemment d'habitations
pour le moment il n'est pas possible
pour les habitants de se rendre chez eux
et donc et bien ils attendent d'en
savoir plus peu d'informations ici vous
l'imaginez bien y compris du côté des
forces de l'ordre ils ne sont pas en
mesure pour le moment de nous dire quand
est-ce que le périmètre sera de nouveau
ouvert donc nous sommes un petit peu
dans l'expectative ici vous l'imaginez
sur place évidemment dans le cinquième
arrondissement et puis et puis aussi ici
en plateau au Figaro avec tibote nous
essayons de vous donner un maximum
d'informations beaucoup de bruit ici en
plateau avec un petit retour mais on va
essayer quand même de vous donner toutes
les informations
pour l'instant 24 blessés 4 sont en
urgence absolue l'incendie et
circonscrit ce sont les dernières
informations données par par la
préfecture nous allons vous en donner un
maximum voilà pour un petit problème de
son c'est réglé
je vous disais donc à l'instant cet
immeuble effondré avec deux personnes
qui sont recherchées dans les dans les
décombres c'est une information du du
parquet les pompiers sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour l'instant une cellule de
crise a été ouverte
250 pompiers sont sur place neufs 70
engins pour parer à aux fuites de cette
explosion des vitres aurait exposé à
plus de 400 mètres de cette explosion
survenue tout à l'heure à 16h50 alors
évidemment pour connaître exactement les
causes de cette de cette incendie qui a
ravagé deux immeubles deux immeubles ce
serait effondrés évidemment on met un
peu de conditionnel dans tout ça parce
que toutes les informations ne sont pas
encore parfaitement arrivées mais nous
essayons de vous les transmettre et
voilà pour pour l'instant on est avec
Timothée sur place Timothée est-ce qu'il
y a de l'agitation j'imagine que oui
autour de vous beaucoup de monde des
riverains des passants qui se demandent
ce qu'il s'est passé qui ont peut-être
entendu l'explosion apparemment c'était
très impressionnant autour
une explosion très impressionnante alors
que vous parliez de d'un certain
mouvement et bien voilà qu'à l'instant
même les policiers nous demandent de
nous écarter c'est une ambulance qui est
en train de passer devant nous nous
sommes je le rappelle rue Saint-Jacques
à quelques centaines de mètres du lieu
de l'explosion tout à l'heure c'est vrai
une certaine agitation et en même temps
on sent que les gens ne savent pas
vraiment on sait pas vraiment ce qui
s'est passé parce que c'est vrai que
vous l'imaginez bien le lieu précis de
l'explosion il y a quelques centaines de
mètres et ici les gens regardent ils
tentent effectivement d'avoir des
informations certains appellent des
proches c'est le cas d'un jeune homme
qui se trouve juste à côté de nous un
proche je l'entends je l'entendais dire
qui se trouve dans l'un des immeubles
proches de cette du lieu où a eu le
l'explosion en tout cas une explosion
extrêmement forte ça c'est une certitude
c'est ce que nous ont confié certains
témoins un homme par exemple qui habite
dans la rue Saint-Jacques donc proche de
du lieu du sinistre et qui a ensuite
quitté la rue pour et bien parce qu'il
devait partir à ce moment-là et qui nous
confiait qu'il ne pouvait plus rentrer
chez lui maintenant qu'il était parti
parce que les forces de l'ordre ont
décidé évidemment de nous parquer et de
bloquer le périmètre
vous arrivez à trouver un riverain
dépassant des gens qui ont entendu cette
explosion des témoins nous sommes
évidemment preneur quelques informations
29 blessés selon un nouveau bilan donc 4
en urgence absolue et 25 en urgence
relative un bilan réviser de la
préfecture de police de Paris qui
indique donc ces chiffres par rapport au
bilan précédent trois personnes en
urgence absolue ont été reclassés une
urgence relative pour une majorité de
ces blessés il s'agit de victimes
collatérales blessées par l'effet du
souffle et les divers projections les
recherches se poursuivent voilà ce que
ce qu'indique la préfecture de police
deux personnes sont actuellement
recherchées sous les décombres ça c'est
le parquet de Paris qui il annonce on a
vu arriver tout à l'heure à nidalgo la
mère de Paris elle était accompagnée de
Laurent Nunez le préfet de police et de
Florence Bertoul la mère du cinquième
arrondissement sachez d'ailleurs de la
mairie du 5e arrondissement ouvre ses
portes pour accueillir les victimes ça a
été posté il y a quelques minutes sur
Twitter les victimes et les équipes
médicales et d'aide aux victimes voilà
pour cette mairie du 5e arrondissement
qui est donc ouverte à tous ceux qui en
ont besoin évidemment certaines
personnes ne pourront pas regagner leur
domicile cette nuit une cellule de crise
a été ouverte par la Mairie de Paris
le maire adjoint premier adjoint à la
mairie de Paris Emmanuel Grégoire publié
d'ailleurs une image de cette série de
crise que vous pouvez retrouver sur
Twitter et sur le fil du figaro.fr avec
ces mots une pensée aux victimes à leurs
proches et au service de sécurité et de
secours qui sont qui sont sur place il y
a une organisation dans ce cinquième
arrondissement la nuit approche du 19h40
et des habitants du secteur qui ne
peuvent pas rentrer chez eux s'organise
pour coucher chez des amis des voisins
des gens qui proposent et c'est ce que
nous expliquera sans doute Timothée
encore des gens qui proposent aux
riverains de venir dormir chez eux à
préparer
pareil événement évidemment la
solidarité est de mise dans le cinquième
arrondissement de Paris il y a des
réactions politiques plusieurs
Mathilde pano par exemple de la France
insoumise grande inquiétude suite à la
violente explosion dans le 5e
arrondissement de Paris le bilan
provisoire et déjà terrible tout mon
soutien ou blessé plusieurs autres
personnalités ont également tweeté comme
Marine Le Pen qui pense aux victimes et
leurs proches nous verrons sans doute
des personnalités politiques venir à
Paris plutôt du côté du gouvernement
Gérald Darmanin devrait se rendre sur
place il était en déplacement à Nancy
aujourd'hui il devrait se rendre sur les
deux de l'explosion en dans la dans la
soirée nous suivrons cela évidemment sur
sur le Figaro live Timothée vous êtes
sur place racontez-nous ce que vous
voyez ce que vous entendez est-ce que
vous voyez encore d'ailleurs un nuage de
fumée parce qu'il était très
impressionnant cet après-midi ce qui est
il y a une odeur de feu dans les rues de
Paris
[Musique]
je sais pas si vous m'entendez est-ce
que vous entendez vous avez une odeur
par exemple de fumée on sait qu'il y a
eu un panache de fumée très
impressionnant dans l'après-midi dans
les rues de Paris est-ce qu'il y a aussi
est-ce que vous voyez au loin cette
fumée de là où vous trouvez à quelques
centaines de mètres de l'explosion de
cet après-midi
ah il est beau c'est pas grave on
retrouvera Timothée dans dans quelques
dans quelques instants je continue à
vous donner certaines informations
sachez que des recherches sont en cours
sous les décombres pour retrouver deux
personnes l'incendie et lui circonscrit
c'est le préfet de police qui l'a lancé
tout à l'heure le rangs les opérations
sont toujours en cours c'est ce qu'il a
annoncé tout à l'heure dans un point
presse on l'a vu avec avec la mère de
Paris l'explosion est survenue pour être
très précis au 277 rue Saint-Jacques
dans le 5e arrondissement à 16h55 à
l'intérieur d'un immeuble qui accueille
l'Académie de mode américaine mais pas
que oui il y a eu une explosion dans
cette dans cette école privée dont je
vous parlerai dans un instant
l'explosion à entraîner immédiatement un
incendie évidemment prise en charge par
les pompiers de Paris deux immeubles
mitoyens ont été évacués après avoir été
déstabilisé par par cette explosion des
vitres ont été soufflées ça c'est ce qui
est indiqué le le préfet de police de
Paris Laurent Laurent Nunez
recherche dans les décombres sont en
cours un message tiens de Rachida Dati
Merl du 7e arrondissement de Paris
explosion dévastatrice survenue dans le
cinquième arrondissement mes pensées
vont aux victimes et à leurs proches et
aussi aux pompiers de Paris qui sont en
cours d'intervention ce qu'on a retrouvé
Timothée Delem on va peut-être essayer
de le retrouver sinon on ira s'imprégner
de l'ambiance sur place Timothée est-ce
qu'il y a une odeur de fumée est-ce que
vous voyez au loin encore des 7 fumée un
incendie dites-nous tout
ça
vous dérangerait de nous raconter
c'est pour rentrer dans les détails
savoir un peu plus
parce que
merci beaucoup
on va y aller dans quelques secondes on
va vous raconter tout simplement ce que
S
je m'en fous de laver et je me
en plus
[Musique]
voilà de retour de retour dans le 5e
arrondissement de la de la capitale vous
le voyez toujours les secours qui sont à
pied d'oeuvre la rue qui est toujours
bloquée nous sommes avec un jeune homme
qui attend de pouvoir avancer parce que
et bien ça petite copine habite à
proximité et là elle est témoin de cette
explosion vous étiez au téléphone de
laquelle à l'instant que vous êtes elle
dit que vous êtes-elle raconté d'abord
elle avait très peur la courue se
réfugier dans l'appartement et elle est
bloquée depuis maintenant deux heures
deux trois heures voilà un peu plus
sortir et je patiente pour la rejoindre
alors sur le moment précis de
l'explosion c'est vrai qu'on essaye de
comprendre un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé où se trouvait-elle précisément se
trouvait sur la place qui est juste à
côté donc elle a entendu l'explosion
elle a senti le souffle et la vue les
vitres se briser donc elle a tout de
suite couru voilà ce réfugier à l'abri
alors on entend certaines personnes
parlent de d'une potentielle double
explosion est-ce que vous avez des
informations également qu'elle vous
aurait communiqué à ce niveau là non
[Musique]
un peu l'oreille droite qui siffle mais
elle est saine et sauve donc c'est c'est
le principal voilà pour ces quelques
informations que que nous que nous donne
ce ce témoin toujours sur place ici avec
cette forte odeur cette forte odeur de
fumée de de cramé et puis toujours les
secours qui sont à pied d'oeuvre on a vu
tout à l'heure passer des quelques
quelques civières malheureusement et
donc voilà on entend toujours certaines
sirènes on voit toujours cette cette
fumée qui s'échappe de cet immeuble
comme vous le montre à l'instant Julien
Julien Leclerc je vous le rappelle c'est
à quelques centaines de mètres de
l'endroit où nous nous trouvons
actuellement et puis toujours cette
forte odeur cette forte odeur de de
cramer ici sur cette sur cette rue
Saint-Jacques
merci Timothée depuis le cinquième
arrondissement de Paris une enquête a
été ouverte pour blessure involontaire
par violation d'une obligation de
prudence ou de sécurité voilà
c'est ce qui a annoncé le parquet de
Paris il y a quelques minutes des
détonations étaient entendus sans que
rien ne permette pour le moment de
déterminer l'origine du sinistre précise
la procureur de Paris leur Bécaud qui se
rendant sur place tout à l'heure elle
était dans le dans le cinquième
arrondissement le dernier bilan je vous
le donne alors on se parle 29 blessés
selon le bilan quatre en urgence absolue
25 en urgence relative ça a été
légèrement modifié trois personnes ont
été reclassées en urgence relative pour
une majorité de ses blessés il s'agit de
victimes collatérales blessées par
l'effet du souffle et des diverses
projections des recherches se
poursuivent parce que deux personnes
seraient sous les décombres c'est ce
qu'a annonçait le parquet de Paris 25 de
pompiers sont à pied d'oeuvre pour
tenter justement de retrouver ces deux
personnes recherchées 9 médecins 70
engins on l'a vu avec Timothée delaime
de la fumée toujours au loin on le voit
un peu sur sur les images une odeur
importante de fumer évidemment dans le
cinquième arrondissement mais cette
exposition qui a déclenché un incendie
tout à l'heure à 16h50 et bien c'est
incendie il est circonscrit c'est ce cas
annoncé ce qu'on annoncé les pompiers
tout à l'heure avec ces deux immeubles
donc qui se sont effondrés dans dans le
cinquième arrondissement de Paris
Timothée Delam vous êtes sur place
pierre tout ce que vous venez de nous de
nous dire à l'antenne vous le voyez
toujours on essaye de filmer on essaie
d'avoir un certain nombre de
d'informations ici ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas évident je sais pas si vous
m'entendez d'ailleurs Thibault
il sent que vous que vous m'entendiez
c'est pas évident ici de trouver une
bonne connexion vous le voyez à
l'instant certains véhicules avec un
nouveau des sirènes et puis toujours
c'est toujours c'est gyrophares au loin
évidemment les pompiers qui sont
présents vous disiez que l'incendie est
circonscrit en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que de ce que nous
voyons il y a toujours de la fumée et
bien qui s'envole dans dans le ciel on
tente de vous le de vous le montrer
l'incendie serait étant on sait que
certains pompiers sont toujours en train
de chercher évidemment
deux personnes sous les sous les décongs
je parle sous votre contrôle Thibault
parce que vous avez davantage
d'informations à ce niveau là que nous
vous voyez en tout cas les
sapeurs-pompiers sur ces images de
Julien Leclerc beaucoup de ça par
pompier qui sont là qui sont en train et
bien de s'agiter
pour et bien voilà faire tout simplement
leur travail d'urgence en ce moment on
cherche toujours à comprendre ce qu'il
s'est passé ici on a vu tout à l'heure
passer également un cortège d'officiel
puisque on le sait un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques sont présentes
sur place ce soir dans le 5e
arrondissement de la capitale c'est le
cas notamment de la mère de Paris Anne
Hidalgo à l'instant vous le voyez ce
sont ce sont des motards on peine à voir
exactement de qu'il s'agit d'ici mais
voilà toujours une situation en tout cas
assez étrange et finalement assez calme
Thibault en tout cas à l'endroit où nous
nous trouvons on voit en fait des gens
qui essayent de comprendre de regarder
de voir de discuter un peu avec les avec
les forces de l'ordre des CRS en
l'occurrence mais voilà on attend on
attend de voir si on peut et bien si la
chaussée va être à nouveau ouverte pour
ceux qui habitent boulevard du
Port-Royal ou bien rue Saint-Jacques et
ici une situation qui est qui est
finalement assez calme
donne 29 blessés 25 sont en urgence
relative 4 sont en urgence absolue c'est
ce qui a indiqué tout à l'heure la
préfecture de police aux alentours de
19h30 il y a une petite demi-heure un
une explosion qui a été entendue à 16h50
des vitres ont été brisées à plus de 400
mètres plusieurs personnes se sont même
demandées un des témoins qui racontent
s'il s'agissait d'un attentat d'un
bombardement ça a été visiblement très
très impressionnant une cellule de crise
a été ouverte par la par la Mairie de
Paris vous pouvez voir ça d'ailleurs des
images postées par le premier adjoint
Emmanuel Grégoire sur son compte Twitter
250 pompiers sont à pied d'oeuvre avec
70 engins des sapeurs-pompiers de Paris
9mins et leur objectif principal
maintenant depuis que le feu est
circonscrit c'est de retrouver ces deux
personnes recherchées elles sont
recherchées sous sous les décombres
elles ont été portées disparues après
l'explosion donc survenu tout à l'heure
à 16h50
dans le dans le cinquième arrondissement
de de Paris avec
cette école privée la Paris américaine
Academy vous pouvez aussi voir sur le
fil Twitter de du sur le fil le direct
du figaro.fr une image avant et après
l'explosion de cette Parisienne Academy
une école une école de mode américaine
au 277 rue Saint-Jacques voilà pour les
premières informations dont nous nous
disposons des personnalités politiques
sont venues sur place tout à l'heure la
maire de Paris Anne Hidalgo la mère du
cinquième arrondissement de Paris
Florence Berthoud elles sont venues
toutes les deux accompagnées du préfet
de police Laurent Nunez qui a fait état
lui dit du premier bilan et dans la
soirée Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur devrait se rendre sur place
il était à Nancy aujourd'hui en
déplacement et donc d'une nuit à l'autre
le ministre de latin de l'intérieur est
attendu dans le dans le 5e
arrondissement Timothée vous êtes sur
place
ce que vous êtes avec des témoins
j'imagine qu'il y a beaucoup de
journalistes autour de vous qui essayent
de comprendre eux aussi ce qu'il s'est
passé
oui tout à fait Thibaut beaucoup de
journalistes autour de nous et c'est la
raison pour laquelle probablement la
connexion peine à passer ici mais voilà
on y arrive je suis actuellement avec
une témoin de ce qu'il s'est passé en
tous les cas vous me disiez à l'instant
que vous êtes auxiliaire puéricultrice
et que vous avez entendu tout à l'heure
à 16h55 cette fameuse explosion
on a cru c'était un tremblement de terre
ça allait mieux raison bouger les
chariots tout et après c'est une Dave
qui était là rendre visite à sa fille
qui nous a dit à regarder il y a de la
fumée et tout et on a été voir
effectivement il y avait de la fumée
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé au moment de
l'explosion on imagine un une ambiance
une atmosphère très très spéciale à
l'endroit où vous étiez en train de
travailler ah bah de la peur
la peur de pas savoir ce qui se passe et
puis après ben tout l'arrivée des
camions pompiers SAMU la police tout
voilà qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que
c'est grave tout et après avec tout ça
on s'est dit ouh là ah oui quand même
puis après on a regardé les infos et on
s'est vu que l'immy était effondrée et
tout
impression on imagine également que vous
avez ressenti cette forte odeur que nous
sentons encore à l'heure actuelle
c'est pour ça qu'après on a fermé les
fenêtres tout mais ouais et vous étiez
bloqué du coup sur votre lieu de travail
comment ça s'est passé là vous venez à
l'instant de pouvoir repartir il me
semble oui nos cadres nous ont dit que
on pouvait partir si on avait nos
relèves qui étaient arrivés d'accord
mais je vous remercie je vous remercie
beaucoup en tout cas pour ces pour ces
quelques éléments et on vous laisse bien
sûr et bien on vous souhaite un prompt
rétablissement après ces émotions on
espère que les personnes qui sont encore
sous les décombres et bien vont être
retrouvés par par les secours que vous
que vous voyez toujours derrière nous et
qui sont toujours évidemment à pied
d'oeuvre
merci Timothée l'origine de l'explosion
et toujours inconnue de premières
investigations sont actuellement menées
par la police judiciaire sur les lieux
de l'explosion il cherche à déterminer
ce qui a pu causer ce drame évidemment
qui a fait au moins 29 blessés c'est le
bilan actuel la piste évoquée pour
l'heure c'est une explosion au gaz
puisque des témoins ont senti une forte
odeur avant avant la de flagration de
personnes sont actuellement recherchés
sous les décombres elles sont portées
disparues et les pompiers qui ont réussi
à circonscrire l'incendie et bien
maintenant son tapis d'oeuf pour tenter
de retrouver ces deux personnes c'est ce
qui a annoncé le parquet de Paris le
bilan il est très clair 29 blessés bilan
à 19h15 pas de nouveau bilan depuis
évidemment nous vous donnons les
dernières informations desquelles ton 29
blessés selon ce bilan 4 en urgence
absolue et 25 en urgence relative et le
nombre de blessés de personnes en
urgence absolue a été un petit peu
abaissé trois d'entre elles sont passées
en urgence relative et la majorité de
ces blessés donc ceux qui sont en
urgence relative et bien il s'agit de
victimes collatérales pour la plupart
qui ont été blessés par l'effet du
souffle par des projections diverses et
évidemment des recherches se poursuivent
des projections et du souffle très
impressionnante certaines vitres ont été
brisées ont exposé à plus de 400 mètres
de
l'incendie de cette explosion
dans la rue Saint-Jacques au 5e dans le
5e arrondissement de Paris voilà pour
les chiffres sachez que la mairie du 5e
arrondissement ouvre ses portes ou ses
portes pour accueillir les les victimes
vous pouvez voir ça d'ailleurs sur sur
Twitter
canal d'information très important
désormais pour accueillir les victimes
et les équipes médicales d'aide aux
victimes comme nous le disait Timothée
autour de la zone tout est bouclé
certains ne peuvent pas rentrer chez eux
certains ont été évacués parce que des
[Musique]
se rendre sur place dans la dans la
soirée il en a l'habitude sur ce genre
sur ce genre d'événements plusieurs
personnalités politiques ont elles
témoigner de leur soutien sur les
réseaux sociaux Mathilde panot par
exemple la présidente du groupe la
France insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
grande inquiétude suite à la violente
explosion dans le 5e arrondissement de
Paris le bilan provisoire est déjà
terrible tout le monde soutient ou
blessés Marine Le Pen également
présidente elle du groupe RN à
l'Assemblée une importante déflagration
et de cet après-midi à Paris suite à une
explosion survenue dans le 5e
arrondissement nous pensons aux victimes
et à leurs proches tout le monde
soutient aux policiers et aux forces de
secours mobilisés sachez qu'Elisabeth
borne a indiqué suivre la situation de
très près voilà pour ces réactions
politiques il faut donner également
celle de Rachid dalati mère du 7e
arrondissement elle qui adressent ses
pensées aux victimes et à leurs proches
également aux pompiers ils sont 250 sur
place donc essayer de retrouver ces deux
personnes de personnes recherchées et
puis d'aider la police judiciaire qui
qui a démarré son enquête une enquête
ouverte par le paquet de Paris pour
blessures involontaire pour essayer de
savoir si il y a eu des manquements à
des obligations de prudence ou de
sécurité dans cette
explosion survenue dans le cinquième
arrondissement de la capitale où vous
trouvez Timothée de l'aime
beau toujours ici dans le cinquième
arrondissement vous le voyez ici ce
barrage de police avec les qui sont ici
attentifs certaines personnes ont pu
passer pour pour rentrer chez elle en
fait c'est du cas par cas les personnes
qui souhaitent pouvoir et bien passer ce
barrage doivent expliquer à ses
longuements qu'ils habitent vraiment
vraiment juste là il y a également
l'hôpital Cochin qui se trouve à
proximité sur cette sur cette rue
Saint-Jacques et donc on a vu par
exemple une médecin urgentiste et bien
qui sortait de du travail et qui a pu et
qui a pu passer mais toujours attention
sous escort et bien avec un CRS qui
l'accompagne à chaque fois qui
accompagne à chaque fois les personnes
pour et bien s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas
de personnes un peu partout sur les sur
les lieux vous voyez toujours ici
beaucoup de journalistes également on va
vous montrer ici certaines chaînes de de
télévision vous voyez ici
est en train de se vider comment
certaines personnes qui sont en train
d'attendre parce que voilà ils essayent
de de peut-être de rester ici de
comprendre ce qu'il ce qu'il s'est passé
un homme tout à l'heure nous confier
qu'il était en train de s'organiser
parce que il est bien il ne sait pas où
il va dormir ce soir finalement parce
qu'il habite à proximité du du lieu du
sinistre et donc il était en train et
bien de joindre des amis pour voir si il
allait pas passer la nuit chez un chez
un ami voilà pour pour ce qui se passe
ici sur place je vous cache pas que on a
du mal aussi à comprendre exactement ce
qui se passait alors qu'à l'instant même
vous voyez sur ces images de Julien
Leclerc voilà ça c'est une scène et bien
qui se répète depuis tout à l'heure des
riverains qui viennent qui viennent
discuter avec avec les CRS pour voilà
leur demander s'ils peuvent passer il
semble qu'ils aient en l'occurrence
obtenu gain de cause c'est le cas d'une
d'entre elles qui va vous allez voir
être comme je vous le disais être
escorté par
ce policier voilà qui va et bien les
ramener peut-être jusqu'à peut-être
jusqu'au bas de leur porte peut-être
jusqu'à leur véhicule voilà toujours
pour pour s'assurer et qu'il n'y ait pas
évidemment trop de badauds à proximité
du sinistre vous le voyez ce dispositif
de sécurité qui est important avec au
moins trois quarts de CRS juste pour ce
qui est de la rue sur laquelle nous nous
trouvons et puis derrière eux et bien ce
sont les sapeurs-pompiers de Paris qui
sont en train toujours d'intervenir sur
les
bien de temps cela va prendre peut-être
sommes-nous partis pour une longue une
longue nuit d'attente vous le disiez
tout à l'heure Thibault certains
immeubles ont probablement été
endommagés par cette par cette forte
détonation et c'est donc la raison pour
laquelle les forces de l'ordre et puis
les et puis les secours ne prennent
évidemment aucun risque toujours cette
fumée que l'on que l'on voit depuis que
l'on voit s'envoler là depuis cette
immeuble et puis cette forte odeur cette
forte odeur de cramé qui persiste même
si l'incendie vous le disiez tout à
l'heure semble être circonscrit à
l'heure où on se parle
merci timoto Delam vous le voyez sur ces
images même si le feu est circonscrit
les pompiers qui continuent d'arroser
cette Parisse américaine Academy et
picentre de cette explosion survenue
tout à l'heure à 16h50 nous restons en
direct évidemment avec ces images pour
suivre toutes les évolutions sur place
après cette exposition dans le cinquième
arrondissement de Paris qui a déclenché
un incendie extrêmement important qui
est à l'heure on se parle circonscrit
les pompiers sont pieds d'oeuvre ils
sont 250 pour tenter de retrouver deux
blessés de personnes
disparues une police la police
criminelle est également sur place
puisque une enquête a été ouverte et
puis des brigades cynophiles sont sur
place pour déterminer s'il peut y avoir
d'autres explosions avec des des cas des
explosifs potentiellement cette piste
emblécarter puisque c'est le gaz qui
serait à l'origine de cette explosion
mais il faut lever tous les doutes et
puis une brigade cynophile également
pour tenter de retrouver ces deux
personnes
recherchées le bilan actuel fait état de
29 blessés dont 4 en urgence absolue en
restant ensemble sur le figarolive avec
ces images depuis la rue depuis le 5e
arrondissement de Paris
et je
[Musique]